so the movie base of the late lamented
show about a 21st century Nancy Drew
Veronica Mars is about to be released
but it doesn't come from Hollywood fans
kicked in over five million dollars on
Kickstarter to make it happen okay we're
live wait for it so this tried to
kick-started movies it's win-win right
wrong I admit that my first reaction to
the Mars movie was positive Veronica
Mars will get a capstone like Firefly
got serenity all right P wash open we'll
never forget you I mean this Kickstarter
thing is every disgruntled children is
dream come true
crowdfunding means that every program
that ended before its time could rise
from the dead but then I watched the
trailer for the Veronica Mars movie a
couple of times I need your help
Veronica I don't really do that anymore
so there's a second or two devoted to an
actual murder mystery followed by
endless in-jokes
I specifically told the agency an
eager-to-please brunette please don't
make me look bad
what I got it Veronica Mars a movie it's
not another Firefly it's a nineteen
eighties TV reunion movie you know like
still the beaver return to Mayberry
return to Green acre is a very Brady
Christmas but crowdfunding has its own
drawbacks if the most ardent fans call
the shots
they'll just okay we will just demand a
fanservice I mean think about a Star
Trek reboot underwritten by the most
committed Trekkies would be two solid
hours of Kirk and Spock make it out
if pausing only to catch their breath
and main Tribble jokes it tears my guts
out to say it but baby shows shouldn't
pander for their most dedicated fans oh
what's happening to me I'm becoming
everything I despise maybe I'll launch a
Kickstarter at my home give me twenty
five hundred and operate the show of
your choice give me two hundred fifty
thousand and I will shut up and go away
forever let me know what you chill out
for in the comments